well a media outlet called the record
which is owned by cyber security company
recently published a story with the
nsa's monitoring of this show
effectively admitting that it happened
our identity the record said was
included in an intel
intercept and then quote unmasked
intercepted of the record rather did not
explain how that would be
legal but it happened as we said it did
glenn greenwald is an independent
journalist you can read him and you
should
on sub stack which is a an unfiltered
uncontrolled website for people who are
independent glenn thanks so much for
coming on tonight so
unmasked why in the world would the u.s
government be unmasking journalists
particularly ones who are critical of
them
yeah i'm sorry i'm trying to keep myself
composed after that emotional footage
i'm sorry and i'm sorry i'm sorry i
didn't i think
yeah i mean you should have given me a
warning i'm i'm really on the verge of
tears myself here after i haven't heard
that
sorry you know i think the the critical
question
is exactly what you just asked which is
when
let's remember that the fundamental
foundation principle is that the nsa is
not supposed to be using its spying
powers on american citizens unless that
first gets a warrant which obviously
didn't have
with regard to you sometimes though they
do find out things that you're doing or
saying
if you're for example talking to
somebody who they are spying on
or people they're spying on are talking
about things you said or done and when
that happens
there's supposed to be protections in
place for american citizens they're
supposed to hide your identity
so that your privacy isn't invaded which
is what happens when they learn things
that you're doing without a warrant
in limited circumstances they have the
right to unmask
the identity of the american citizen who
appears in their record and then
disseminate it through the intelligence
community for example if they listen to
people saying we want to kill
journalist a of course they would want
to unmask it to warn
the journalist that they're being
targeted none of that happened here
and yet where is the media complaining
about it the washington post actually
published a story by their media critic
eric gwempel who
has no experience reporting on
surveillance
justifying that the nsa did this and
claiming that you have no grounds for
complaining about what conceivable
justification is there
tucker for the nsa to have gone and said
we want to know this journalist's name
who is trying to get an interview with
vladimir putin and the reason the media
doesn't care in fact supports the nsa
is because they're on the side of the
intelligence community and are very
happy when those powers are abused
for ideological ends against their
ideological enemy which i'm sorry to say
includes you
well that's exactly what it was i mean
they spread to news outlets that i was
talking to russians in an effort to
discredit and then control me
of course that's the point that's why we
don't allow it so i want to get your
reaction
uh speaking of federal powers that may
be abused buzzfeed reported that most of
the people
involved in that famous plot right
before the election to kidnap the
governor of michigan gretchen whitmer
were in fact working for the fbi you've
covered a lot of these stories over the
years were you surprised by that
most of them were working for the fbi
you know i think that as americans we
are trained and i know i
even after all all the reporting i've
done to kind of reflexively disbelieve
that the fbi could do something like
involve itself in a plot and then either
encourage it or allow we all have that
kind of instinct no that wouldn't have
happened
but what i'm telling you is i spent a
decade
during the first war on terror this is
the second war on terror reporting in
one case after the next where the fbi
would say
we caught four young muslims plotting to
blow up a bridge
and in almost every case it turned out
that these four young muslims were
not very smart were emotionally unstable
were financially vulnerable
and the only plot that was created was
one that was created by the fbi that
brought it to them and then used their
know-how of psychological manipulation
to lure them into it
the informants who were paid would do
everything possible to get them to agree
to it and then the fbi would announce oh
we found this plot that was actually the
fbi's pot in the first place
so the only unanswered question that
that committee should be asking
instead of in between all the sobbing
and weeping and stuff is
what role did the fbi have in terms of
being embedded
in the three groups they claim plotted
this
attack on the capital and did they
purposely allow it to go forward because
as the fbi has admitted
we need the citizenry and fear in order
to increase our budget in order to
increase our
surveillance authorities and the one
relevant question
about january 6 that hasn't been
answered is the one that the media and
the congress has declared off limits to
ask
boy they hate it and in fact republican
members of congress were given
instructions by their leaders not to
push the fbi on this which is just
mind-blowing but we should push i think
we should
and thank you for doing it glenn
greenwald of substance great to see you
hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else